[Music]
in science verse culture News submitted
by you to homie thousands of protesters
are hoping to stop the construction of a
telescope in Hawaii Oh another telescope
what's the first one there's a big one
on Maui and another one a big island
there's one called the shaka laka
telescope this is a new one
actually this takes place on the Big
Island
this mountain in Hawaii is called Mauna
Kea and so there are already 13
telescopes on this mountain but they've
been wanting to create this 1.4 billion
dollar telescope called 30-meter
telescope or TMT how much [ __ ] are they
trying to see there's already 13 [ __ ]
telescopes on there they can't see
enough time no God yeah so they're
saying that this muta scope would rise
about 18 stories tall that's a big one
yeah and so in 2009 that's when Mauna
Kea was chosen for the TMT and so since
then there have been protests because
this is a very sacred mountain they were
already constructed so much and like
defiled it pretty much so much that
they're the people of Hawaii are just
saying like [ __ ] this man enough is
enough
like stop [ __ ] with our sacred
mountain code they're saying that this
is a deeply sacred place for Hawaiian
ribs huh sorry probably loops Pele is
the volcanic goddess I'm not sure I
don't know how much about the lowing
gods but she lives where lavaliere yeah
but they are saying that this is a
shrine for worship and it is a home to
the gods but I don't know which god they
should have been like we're trying to
see the gods that's why we want to build
this let's talk with them yeah
no but you wouldn't put it on top of it
because you don't see it yeah so all
right cuz dukkha lives there yeah and
they also say that's like the one of the
best observation points which is why
they wanted their 1959 when American
scientists they've decided that that's
the best place on earth watch who
observes space there's no light
pollution 1:13 then you got 13 you guys
are getting greedy
demolishor you then Bing so the
government had promised like okay we're
gonna get rid of a few telescopes to
make room for this new telescope but
then they back down on their promise and
they wonder Native Hawaiian heirs hate
everybody and then they okayed a whole
nother chunk of the mountain for this
telescope and that's why they're pissed
who okayed it the government so Hawaii
has no say in it they've never had to
say their state just got taken by the US
like they were like we don't want it and
then us was like well yeah you're part
of us sorry sorry sorry
I know so here's some photos what does
Brett man have to say about this that's
all I care about
he's a Angelino not only being yeah he's
not he hates all eh well my boo has a
lot to say about this [ __ ] no but I it
is so here's like some of the protests
they should have made the telescope into
a coconut and I think they would have
been okay if like if those fur around
and a couple Tiki tree I mean yeah tiki
torches ever here seeing my boo with his
Hawaiian yeah I thought he was Samoan
he's a lion I always get this wrong
there's a lot of simone's in Hawaii
yes born there they feel like yeah oh so
Jason Momoa was born there yeah he's
from Hawaii I guess I guess cuz Momoa
Samoa I just thought he was so long what
does Aquaman have to say look at look at
my boobs
what does that say we are Mauna Kea yeah
you know why yes
Jeff why did he have to like do it like
that and show those muscular pecs like
that's good if it's the model did that
honor
it will go viral yeah so I'm gonna read
the message you're like what she had
riding on her ass these boobs are bigger
than mine
what is that all you have to say what no
I mean you thought that was gonna help
well I mean he's just wrap shirts aren't
like the deepest like his English is
like questionable like when he drives
I'm just like do you speak another
language is that
grievous Kevin what is it try to help or
not is like the wheel place she's trying
to help each other out he's a really
cool guy like he's a bad no I love them
too but I'm just saying like but you
also if you're trying to help try to
help are you the best ambassador for I'm
not judging I'm just saying that he's
not helping in that way you you be nice
about Jason Momoa the women defend Jason
Momoa the guys go wrong
you'd be nice Hawaiian people lined up
over there that's helping he's taking
sexual photo chefs if you will be good
it's like a natural disaster Instagram
model yeah he's going like this and then
he has a I'm waiting for the nude photo
of him covering his privates and it's
just being like telescope how many how
many hits did that photo work you're
like not enough that's it
Nicole Scherzinger yes so what you guys
say about that she's a pussycat yeah the
lead the lead see why I don't know
I thought she was alien oh wait isn't
she Filipino I think everyone's Filipino
did you think she's of Hawaiian descent
well you don't have to be Hawaiian to
protect Hawaii okay are there any other
devices any white guys that have
telescope on their chest like they're
battling it out
I'd imagine fighting for the telescope
hey but listen not releasable
felicitous bow not just Hawaiians are
doing this look Clark who Oh
emilia clarke why does she look nine she
looks really young she's always looking
I thought Khaleesi was back what way
black white hair no like a like albino
black what what I didn't know that's
what she looked like in real life she's
like she's like very white British I
thought she was like half black half
white but then like you know how like
there's like black girls that look like
that they're like half black half white
but then they look like more white yeah
[Laughter]
no she looks like albino on a real hair
damn Denarius you lied to me Oh like
good guys real me white that's that's
cute oh you don't watch all the YouTube
videos that pop up were things about
herself I've only seen Santa's real life
it takes like four hours to put the wig
on still looks fake as [ __ ]
yeah just put it on can't think like do
it and then put it on they put one and
and her hair changes every single
episode so it's extremely ornate that
bugs me cuz I'm like [ __ ] in the middle
of a war why don't have time to do your
hair Queen you know what bugs me is that
brand gets hella all that it's supposed
to be in the same like year really it
was like no real time oh okay yeah it
doesn't feel like there's a lot of time
that bothers me that brand is in a
wheelchair but the whole thing is not
wheelchair accessible oh yeah yeah
that's [ __ ] up I know after a hoarder
left who the [ __ ] is carrying him around
okay well I win that's my eyes I would
do that I would say that up going back
to Hawaii going back to Hawaii right
it's kind of their fault that there's no
light pollution there my small they need
to add
the world it's extreme on you guys if
they have a lot of lights on then no
one's gonna wanna [ __ ] put a telescope
there put a bunch of street lights up
around the Mauna Kea and then nobody
wants to telescope it's late yeah but it
seems like it's another broken promise
by the government where they said right
that they were gonna remove some of the
other telescopes and build this life you
know how they got Hawaii they said they
were gonna do a democracy like a
democratic vote and everybody could
participate and vote on whether or not
Hawaii would like to be part of the
United States and then they locked up
the Queen during the voting process and
they had a vote but it was only the
people that wanted it to be part but
also they it was a military coup around
1550 is something around there but
surely that's not how America was
founded a state Nikia
huh the way that they became a state
yeah yeah oh because I was thinking
about previously when they destroyed the
monarchy oh I was thinking about how
they became a state oh damn I didn't
know that yeah because basically we they
needed to secure the u.s. to fight
because they thought if we don't secure
it then Japan's gonna get it right which
is probably what your I would've done
yeah those sneaky bastards that many
Japanese there at the time ready imagine
like viewing the other dimension and
when that did happen what how different
would today there's a show on Amazon
called man and a high castle philip k
dick that's actually from a novel yeah
and they it's crazy so it's an alternate
universe where Germany and Japan
actually won any divided us all in the
west coast is owned by Japan all on the
East Coast is owned by Germany yeah it's
a pretty to the good stuff yeah like if
the war went the other way
that's crazy yeah it's cool you read it
yeah I recommend watch it too no I
watched a bleep Amazon Prime like just
came in the last year to Canada I don't
know if it's been a yeah I could be
wrong honey we have prime like delivery
man look I don't know technology okay
even Game of Thrones I caught up the
entire series I watched this year I'm
like a season 1 let's go catching up cuz
these fools made me watch it but while
the last season was going on so I'm
still like at the end of season six oh
you're almost there it only gets worse
what I'm drawing a blank but who's the
owner of Facebook yeah why doesn't he
make good and make nice and then he can
invest a little bit of money into it and
get good with Hawaii and then he could
be locked up with Hawaii - he bought a
ton of land or what do you do I know
that I mean but he could make you can be
good yeah you wanted to build up a wall
well he did build a wall it used to be
that you couldn't buy property there
unless you were a native I know why they
change it but money talk because there's
not a lot of natives left I think we
made someone that was like 60% native
yeah then she was like yeah and she was
telling me about the inner politics of
Hawaii and what she was saying is that
there's so many different native groups
- because there's different islands and
whatever and everyone kind of claims
lineage to the royal family but not
really and recently we did that one
JK news of the one of the remaining
princesses remember she was a she was
she's some kind of scandal with her and
her sugar baby she was a lesbian lady
yeah but yeah there's just so much [ __ ]
going on and I think that's why it's
difficult to have one thought one
government because they're not the
natives are not all unified as one group
it's not monolith what side do you guys
see you guys see hey there's 13 this is
just one more who cares it's 14 what's
the difference I think if you made a
promise or do you guys see or do you
guys see hey we already done 13 one more
is too much [ __ ] I think it's I
think they could have just stuck to
their [ __ ] promise and be like hey we
know we've been [ __ ] up but at least
looks like let's clean up some of this
[ __ ] we could put the new one here
like yeah more beautiful - like they
need to just leave it the [ __ ] way it
is cuz it's already destroyed in like
Oahu I think there's a wise person once
said fool me once shame on me I love
that person told me twice well you're
not gonna fool me again
goddamn you're not gonna fool me again
fool me again Maggie starts off with I
don't know where I heard this probably
could be Tennessee these high fiber
sources yeah it was stupid